oh go impress my name is Pierre welcome
back to the small R is thus I mean Part
B that's the hands of a guy like that
both handsome fella alright so here the
continuation is kind of where obviously
you need an egg in the basis gigantic
monuments mate
well obviously I stopped ours up I let's
check up here it's not a be a be a drill
I'll held dogs get him don't do
something under huh
calm down holy [ __ ] ah me hi hi P I am
not be careful a night of eggs in the
key to the dark 11 yeah that is too
scary
can't miss music too scary hmm okay
thanks my girlfriend would love this I'm
sorry sorry
break your luck in there alright yeah I
know you can never trust this little
[ __ ] but I I do appreciate the kinder
token them he wants one that's why
you're angry
do you want one I wondered is that you
sad about dad
I can't do it alright I'll just put it
here no I'm not killing anyone
okay we can't still not go down there
I'm super confused where the [ __ ] am I
supposed to go [ __ ] dogs everywhere
oh I know maybe the eggs there's
something about the situation ha ha
how did not work obviously need an egg
alright there we go I have an egg what's
your problem I need a big one I'm so
stupid
don't kill me just one this egg Kim then
open a collapsed one milk a cow whoa
loud very good that's good alright let's
continue is it really serious cousin
sorry thank you there's only four
hardcore horror people this [ __ ] like if
you haven't played it well that's what
I'm talking about right here oh hell no
a disco party in my hello I don't want
to disco was it yeah whoa he looks mean
okay I can stand on these alright gotta
make this second jump
what oh no oh thank god you look scary
stop it
alright go three all right what's down
here
oh hey are you there now there is he
good weather down there
no you know not gonna talk to me why not
I'd do anything I didn't put you down
there you know I get the feeling we're
gonna see if this is [ __ ] a reference
pretty soon but that's again like I had
licked a lot of [ __ ] Oh what the hell
[Music]
shut up I told you not to talk to me in
that tone goddamn [ __ ] okay I can't
walk through these I can't all right
Kent all right check this one out then
hello Wow who are ya yeah what the hell
is this
Shh you're creepy I don't like it there
you want from me alright uh of course it
is a pony now tell me a pony help me my
cute little bunny angel ran into this
dungeon just get shut up
too scared to open this bike can you
don't down look so sad everything would
be okay little funny
god damn it can you open the door at
least I'm just gonna cry beside a locked
door I don't have the [ __ ] key can
you find him no I can no you know what
no I can't I can't help you stop with
that squealing [ __ ] hey we're going whoa
poor little bunny
everyone share the [ __ ] out I just want
the bunny Oh No what the hell do you
have a bunny
Oh No take the hand that mean hell no
hell no okay okay forget we're good
we're good we're good
again we're good let's give that [ __ ] a
bunny here we go where I am trying to
give you your stupid bunny I think it's
over here
is it still after me all right I have
your back
okay guys I don't want it you don't want
your stupid bunny there you go oh thank
you
for the labs in that madam uh puget bras
have a good time in there I'm just gonna
hang out over here right now
what the [ __ ]
ah ha ha ha I'm not oh god panting me
pony goddamn it
[ __ ] ponies man it had got them
creepy [ __ ] shut up no no I don't like
it here got them pony oh [ __ ]
never thought they were so creepy Oh
what the hell Mario your car moving
bikes slipping smash breath all right
huh I'm standing on you turn on yeah
let's go wow I 70 Chef Luigi Grand Prix
hey [ __ ] whoa
oh [ __ ] I'm tired but it's very rude you
know very good why the [ __ ] what's your
problem man nice [ __ ] all right what's
going on fellas control that hey you
I want the bone all right that's good
isn't it not really but
I can do this [ __ ] hey I want an apple
or I will call you fatty for lifetime I
want the butter trying right let's find
their stupid [ __ ] I guess look at the
honey honey
like what
all right what are you come here what
you're gonna lick my [ __ ] again
okay I'll take that
not sure where the [ __ ] you got it from
but who wanted the bone all right shut
up for one second
who wanted about Apple bata all right
here is this stupid bone
of course I make total sense
all right an apple and a fish
goddamn what is this oh it's Apple all
right
they got what is gonna bankrupt
all right you wanted the Apple take it
of course yes
and you wanted what about though but how
let's find this bottle of it [ __ ] yeah
shut up do you have the bottle yes okay
oh yeah it's Mario huh all right
everyone got what they wanted all right
let's go together
hey wait for me right for me another
batch is that [ __ ] sound you're shot
half damaged aah aah I don't punch me
come on here you go
Hey boom ah iodine what the hell man
Jack Nicholson off cars you could summon
a penguin by eating a flowerpot
now that would be even cooler than your
low self-esteem what is there something
you're hiding from me Puma now what the
[ __ ] is this guy dude can you stop it so
annoying so annoying
yeah damn it can't kill them all right
boomer then shut up you know come on you
little [ __ ] oh hi fellow fee man
can a man die it's creepy when you die
actually then it's size again in the
sitting treatment of course anything a
flower but oh that's all right eight
that Jack Nicholson told you not that
that's right
nah hey it was always it was right oh my
god Dapeng man you crazy
well done penguin I'll just correct this
guy cause he's pissing me off you're
driving the wrong direction did i right
[ __ ] [ __ ] you tell you now oh my god
all right and you later pen thank you
for coming
I can add some trick maja not that year
again alright I guess this is very
unique part states uh I left here like
very few enjoy drill and subscribe to
come breath today and I'll see you next
episode
that's pretty much it
[Music]
I got a miser